you
I've grown is cherry here's another cool
chess puzzle that I came across recently
one by Sergey
I've watched chanko this is a puzzle
I've already shared on both Twitter and
Facebook if you're connected with me
there you've likely already seen this I
normally don't run it like that but
after reflecting some I felt that this
puzzle certainly had its place in the
cool chess puzzles playlist so it's
white to move in this one as usual if
you'd like to try and figure this one
out on your own now would be the time to
go ahead pause the video white to move
try and find the best continuation okay
the solution to this one is not very
many moves deep in fact it's only two
moves deep and then the game is over
that's it the first thing one needs to
understand is that white cannot win this
position white needs to come up with
some very clever way to draw this the
very tempting move let's say of Queen to
f8 is faulty going to f8 with the
intention of meeting a king move with
Queen takes Queen well that's illegal
it's important to note that when black
the black king moves it's the white king
who is now in check so Queen f8 is not
working the only move that works the
best continuation the drawing
continuation is to start out with a
Queen sacrifice Queen to e3
why to this square well it is now
setting up a very clever second move
after King takes Queen we now have rook
to g3
blocking the check against the White
King and now delivering a double check
to black there is no time to take the
rook or the bishop and double check the
king must Ollie's move and in this
position the black King has four options
and what really caught my attention with
this one is the final
position it does not matter which of
these four squares the black King goes
to let's just say King to e4 regardless
of whatever four squares he goes to from
this position it's already game over
this final position is stalemate a very
very very clever stalemate the rook
cannot move it is pinned to the king the
bishop cannot move it is pinned to the
king and the Queen cuts off all the
other critical squares certainly a
puzzle first-of-its-kind for me I
haven't seen a stalemate puzzle quite
like this where we have just one check a
Queen sacrifice followed up with another
check and then a reply with now I double
check in regardless of where black goes
the final position now being stalemate
with pins every which way and the King
has mentioned already cut off so really
cool puzzle I think I think you'll like
this one feel free to leave any feedback
to this video and as always I hope you
enjoyed it that's all for now
take care
you